we are with the number two player in the
world fabiano caruana fabi traditionally
the grand chess tour rapid and blitz
events don't go so great for you but
this one second place
great result
yeah i'm happy with it uh i mean today
was a good day for me plus two and i
think i played reasonably well in some
games
um
so yeah it was it was good i mean
unfortunately hikaru ran away with it
um i mean i thought maybe if i have a
good blitz day today maybe there's some
still some hope
uh but even with plus two he increasedly
by point so
it was very hard of course losing the
game but was kind of crucial at the
start losing the game against him today
was crucial
absolutely your year has not gone the
best for you in your events do you feel
like maybe this is the turnaround
i hope so um yeah it's been i mean not
the best is an understatement
like every every event i've has been a
huge disappointment um
except for why consider the start of the
year since then it's just been
disappointment after disappointment
so this is a nice little bounce back
warmed up for the sinkfield cup
you feel like this was good preparation
uh classical is so different it's hard
to say um
yeah i don't know um
i mean it gives me some optimism because
i i think overall i had uh
i mean it was up and down but i think in
some games i actually was i was quite
proud of some games and the quality was
there sometimes um but classical is a
whole different story the first game you
played against uh peter today must have
just given you great joy the way you
put it off pulled off that attack
actually i the thing is uh like when i
saw rook g7
um i was i was very happy i thought this
was the end of the game and then rookie
six comes on the board
and i think oh my god i'm losing
because d6906 is just i have one move
which doesn't lose i thought how can how
is this possible i'm upper rook i'd be
sorry i'm i'm taking his rook i'm up a
bunch of pawns and i'm attacking him and
i lose my rook and i thought this is and
then i saw rook c5 and it was a huge
relief that i
thought i have this movie i don't lose
on the spot
uh fabi if you don't mind uh we just
bring up the game and just for our
audience if you would just uh tell us uh
i apologize if you could repeat what you
were just mentioning
after rook takes g7 right here yeah no i
i calculated up to rookie five
rookie six d6 and that was into my
calculations
i mean when i took on g7 this was the
end of my calculations and then suddenly
after rookie six i see knight f6 is is
coming and
and take uh on the f7 queen e5 and
everything's defended and so it took me
like i don't know a minute to see this
rook c5
i see so you got here and then suddenly
this move knight f6 tasered you the move
before that i i paused uh
after rookie six right you're because
attack
your rook is attacked and by fortu good
fortune yeah yeah it was queen is
attacked yeah pardon me it was a very
very lucky break of course nice it was
genius
from start to finish if i saw it from
the start sure yeah
i didn't beautiful uh
so
sing field cup coming up grand chess
tour
you may not win the tour but you might
put yourself in a position to win some
extra cash
if you win the stingfield cup you're
right there to maybe add another 50k
it's that motivation
i don't know the standings uh i guess i
i
i pretty much doubled two tournament my
last two tournaments in one here so
so that's good um
but i don't know if i have a chance like
i guess
winning the big bill cup you're right
there first place is so heavily weighted
um
yeah then then
but that's uh you know that's a long way
off uh
but yeah i still have some optimism now
that uh after a good result here i still
have a chance at something
some standing of course that
we'll show you the standings we'll bring
it up just to give you a little bit more
motivation than you already have i'm
sure but here are the standings at the
moment you're sitting on fourth place
at 16 and a half a win will put you at
29 and a half with some some good
fortune if
your leading competitors don't
do too well in the sink field cup you
could add 13 points and maybe add some
extra change as well
i mean i'm kind of lucky that
like half the players have played less
events than me
that helps quite a lot
[Laughter]
yeah that's the main reason i'm still
running that
that i've actually showed up at the
event
all right well
good luck and please show up to the next
one in a couple of days look forward to
seeing
[Laughter]
dancing field cup especially now
oh that was great maurice
that's going to go oh boy oh man
you get paid up
not an important part of success let's
take a look again i actually want to see
those standings